6 14 on your Thursday morning Sherry a
piece of Las Vegas entertainment history
is coming back to life that's right the
neon museum is set to re-light the
iconic Lido de parisan the famous show
Marquis the event itself well a lot of
people are going and Laura negretti is
there with a sneak peek for us this
morning and she joins us live from the
museum can't wait to see it all in
lights again Lauren
you and me both Sherry looking forward
to that you said that beautifully by the
way yeah right now I've got the Stardust
Hotel sign behind me that's because it
was the home of course of the Lido De
Paris and with me here I got a special
guest Aaron Berger executive director of
the museum now Erin this is going to be
a great relighting ceremony here it is
it is a sold out event but you know
sneak peek yeah um there's going to be
several you know Tales of from the cast
and crew and you've got a fun tale to
tell us about Katy Perry of all people
of all people exactly so one of the
great things is if you see the Katy
Perry show she stands on stage and talks
about being at Resorts World Resorts
World was the or is now the home of
where the Stardust was so this is a
chance for her to talk about her own
family history her mother and her
grandmother were involved in the Lido
show one was on stage one was a
seamstress in back and so she's now
perform farming at Resorts World in her
residency and so it kind of brings it
all full circle for her so that Lito's
story is Alive and Well in so many
different aspects that's amazing and you
also want to share want people to share
their own Tales of Lido correct a
hundred yes please please please we want
people to go ahead and send us your
photos send us that picture the ashtray
or the the matchbook or your family
photo from when you went and saw the
Lido show together and send it put it on
Facebook put it on on Instagram and tag
the museum we want to capture these
stories perfect thank you so much Aaron
well we're going to keep talking about
these like you said capturing the
stories as the re-illumination kind of
kicks off here later tonight for now
live at the neon Museum Lauren negretti
8 News Now
oh my God that is the coolest thing Katy
Perry's relatives a part of the Lido De
Paris and no wonder she wanted to be at
that resource role because that's where
the Stardust was that's right yeah Baron
said amazing how much history you can
learn just you know listen a little bit
but boy just walking through there and
and the people who know the history of
those signs and and listening and
hearing the stories and just so Dare I
ask Nate Sherry did you get a chance to
go see Nito De Paris absolutely okay I'm
trying to remember if I saw that show I
know I saw the Chippendales there well
hey Sherry they're still around after
Lido they they put in a new show called
enter the night okay which was a big one
as well right I don't think I saw Lido I
don't know when it closed was it before
94. I think so oh absolutely well see I
didn't come till 94. okay so I never got
a chance it's how long we're talking
about here tell us your story share your
stories yes absolutely wow that is so
cool about Katy Perry